- La Légion étrangère, c'est une famille et surtout un état d'esprit.
Le légionnaire.
Quand vous allez gagner votre képi blanc, vous allez comprendre.
On devient légionnaire et on le reste jusqu'à la mort.
- Je veux voir personne ici !
Allez ! Derrière !
Il reste là.
Daniel, départ aligné !
Daniel, aligne-toi !
Tu bouges encore le bras comme ça, je te casse la main !
- Même si je fais une crise cardiaque, je bouge pas, OK ?
Rigueur !
Discipline.
- Je n'abandonne jamais ni des morts, ni des blessés, ni des armes.
- Quand tu mets le képi, d'accord ?
Ici, après, comme ça.
C'est pas ici.
Comme ça, d'accord ?
Ici...
Normal. D'accord ?
Lève-toi, lève-toi.
- Marche !
Gauche, gauche, gauche, gauche, gauche.
Ralentis.
Arrête.
Tous les matins au fort de Nogent,
l'un des deux centres de recrutement de la Légion étrangère,
quelques hommes venus du monde entier
se portent candidats pour un engagement de 5 ans.
Ils vont changer de nom
et, pour les Français de nationalité, devenir étrangers,
car la Légion accepte les Français,
mais à condition qu'ils prennent une nationalité d'emprunt.
- Pour quelles raisons vous êtes venu à la Légion étrangère ?
Mais que les raisons principales.
- L'aspect sportif, l'aspect voyage, aussi.
- L'aventure, quoi.
- Ouais, c'est ça. - A présent, votre nom de famille, c'est plus Revel, mais
Rossini...
Christophe.
Vous êtes né le 6 novembre 1982 à Toronto.
Donc à présent, vous êtes plus français, mais canadien.
OK, c'est bon.
- Pourquoi vous voulez vous engager dans la Légion étrangère ?
- Parce que j'ai pas envie de traîner dans la rue,
j'ai envie de travailler,
et j'ai envie de travailler pour l'Etat français.
J'ai envie de faire un travail intéressant par rapport à moi.
- Est-ce que vous avez des antécédents judiciaires ?
- C'est-à-dire ? Des problèmes avec la justice, tout ça ?
- Oui.
Quoi ?
- Convocation au poste de police.
- Pour quelle raison ?
- Baston.
- A partir de maintenant, vous n'avez plus le droit de contacter
qui que ce soit d'extérieur pendant la période de sélection.
La sélection a lieu à Aubagne.
Chaque jour, une trentaine de candidats y arrivent.
Sur ces 30, quatre seulement deviendront légionnaires.
Une chance sur 8 donc pour que Rossini, le nouveau Canadien,
ou Maynard, le Camerounais, soient engagés.
Tous espèrent devenir légionnaires et coiffer le fameux képi blanc.
- Vous allez chez le caporal-chef là-bas, le long des murs.
Vous allez vous déshabiller, vous enlevez les vestes, les pantalons
et vous restez en slip.
Allez, c'est parti !
Chaussettes.
Ils se retrouvent avec leur nouveau nom
et tous les mêmes sous-vêtements.
- 1, 2, 3...
- Un slip chacun. Vous distribuez, vous donnez les chaussettes à chacun.
Pendant les 15 jours qui viennent,
beaucoup d'entre eux vont être éliminés,
mais dès le départ, ils doivent se mettre dans une nouvelle peau.
- Faites passer les tee-shirts.
Pareil là-bas.
Vous mettez les tee-shirts.
Si c'est trop petit, vous échangez entre vous.
OK ?
Chacun des tests qui vont suivre sera éliminatoire.
- Ca, c'est le test.
On va faire l'exemple ensemble.
Quatre réponses, c'est bon.
Ca, c'est ça, oui ou non ?
Dès le 1er soir, le caporal-chef Ordon, un Polonais,
va leur donner les bases.
- En silence ici, là.
Vous rigolez ou quoi ?
A la Légion étrangère,
on a tout le monde, ex-avocats, ex-PDG, pilotes MiG-25,
chefs de section d'Armée rouge, jusqu'aux clodos.
Chacun a eu sa chance, il est resté, il a fait les choses.
C'est à vous de montrer que vous méritez de mettre votre képi blanc
et montrer surtout avec ça, votre coeur, le muscle ici,
ce que vous pouvez faire pour la Légion étrangère,
pour la gloire de la Légion étrangère
et pour notre patrie d'accueil, la France.
Et pour l'instant, vous allez fermer votre clapet ici.
Je veux le silence total.
A la Légion étrangère, on ouvre le clapet légèrement,
grade de caporal minimum, 2 ou 3 missions en extérieur effectuées.
Là, y a de quoi tchatcher.
Pour l'instant, vous mangez quand il faut manger,
vous dormez quand il faut dormir.
Est-ce que c'est clair ?
- Oui, caporal-chef.
- C'est pas clair pour tout le monde. Est-ce que c'est clair ?
- Allez, top.
Les seuls que la Légion n'accueille pas par principe
sont les auteurs de crimes de sang et les trafiquants de drogue.
- 5... 6... 7.
Ils ont une minute pour prendre leur douche
et ensuite un quart d'heure pour ranger leur dortoir.
- C'est chaud, c'est speed et tout.
On doit se presser, on doit faire les trucs bien,
sinon après, ça nous crie dessus, ça nous gueule.
On est obligés de faire bien, d'être bien attentifs à ce qu'on fait,
parce que sinon, on va recommencer,
et si on recommence, c'est pas bon du tout.
- Tout le monde est dans le même bain que nous,
donc on essaie de s'aider et puis voilà.
Liénard est un ancien gendarme.
La vie militaire, il l'a déjà pratiquée.
- C'est carré, c'est strict.
C'est ce qu'il faut à certaines personnes
pour les motiver un petit peu.
- Qu'est-ce qui vous motive, vous, alors ?
- La hiérarchie, l'esprit militaire.
- Là, c'est quoi, ça ?
Y a des poils.
Venez. Venez tous les deux ici, là.
Les spécialistes, là.
Là, c'est quoi, cette crasse, là ?
Ca part avec mon doigt, avec les ongles.
C'est pas bon. C'est pas un p*tain de foyer pour les réfugiés, ici.
Vous êtes dans la caserne,
A la Légion étrangère, la caserne, c'est notre maison.
C'est comme ça, chez toi ?
Quoi ?
Allez, le matériel, il est là-bas.
Quand vous faites quelque chose,
vous faites exactement comme chez vous, à la maison.
La caserne à l'armée, surtout à la Légion étrangère, Messieurs,
c'est pire qu'une clinique privée parce que c'est chez nous.
Ce sera bientôt chez vous ici.
Est-ce que c'est clair ?
- Oui, caporal-chef !
- Nickel chrome.
On verra ça.
Voilà.
Ici, réveil demain matin, 4h45,
donc il n'y a pas de place pour les grasses matinées.
Vite fait, vous sortez de votre lit, rasage, les lits sont faits,
donnez un coup dans la piaule, vous sortez à l'extérieur.
C'est clair ?
- Oui, caporal-Chef.
- Nickel chrome.
Repos.
- Tous les jours, c'est des épreuves. Mais il faut réussir à les passer et à les
réussir, surtout.
Mais c'est bien, c'est des challenges prouvés à soi et aux autres,
de quoi on est capable.
Il faut être fier d'être légionnaire.
Je suis déjà fier d'y être entré.
Donc si je le suis, c'est encore mieux.
- On verra demain comment ça...
La suite du programme.
Les tests psychotechniques, je suis pas sûr de les avoir réussis.
Donc on verra la réponse demain.
- Ca me ferait quand même chi*r d'arrêter
par rapport aux tests psychotechniques qu'on a passés aujourd'hui.
Mais je crois que ça va aller.
Après, demain, on attaque une nouvelle journée.
On oublie celle-ci et en avant.
- Bonne nuit.
- Bonne nuit, caporal-chef !
- N'oubliez pas le réveil, 4h45, demain matin.
Dès le réveil, ils vont découvrir lesquels parmi eux
ne passeront même pas un 2ème jour ici.
- Maynard !
- Présent, caporal-chef !
- Rossini.
- Sabi !
Youn !
- Je pense que c'est fini.
- Ah ouais ? - Ouais.
- Direction Paris, hein.
- On retourne chez nous.
- J'ai grave les boules, là.
Parce que là, c'est direction le quartier et voilà.
P*tain... Ca fout la haine.
Rossini et Maynard sont éliminés.
Ils pourront se représenter une prochaine fois s'ils le souhaitent.
La première journée, c'était comment marche le cerveau.
Pour ceux qui restent, la 2ème journée, c'est comment va le corps.
- Tests médicaux, maintenant.
Prochaine étape : test sportif.
Toujours aussi confiant qu'au début.
Pas de problème.
Motivé à 200%.
- T'as jamais eu de problème aux genoux, aux chevilles, tout ça ?
Pas de dr*gues, pas de... Tu f*mes ou pas ?
- Non, du tout.
- Avale de la salive.
- A priori, il est apte, pour vous ?
- A priori, il est apte.
Il doit pas y avoir de problème particulier.
Il est en bonne forme, c'est un bon sportif.
Donc ça devrait très bien se passer pour lui.
En tout cas, au niveau médical, y a aucun problème.
*- 45 secondes.
1er test physique :
courir de plus en plus vite sur une vingtaine de mètres.
Ceux qui n'arrivent pas avant le bip du haut-parleur
perdent des points.
*- 45 secondes.
30 secondes.
Lim Lemeyer est américain.
Il vient de San Diego, Californie.
L'une des épreuves essentielles pour la Légion :
les entretiens de motivation.
C'est au tour de Lim de passer devant le patron de cette sélection,
le lieutenant polonais à la Légion depuis 17 ans.
- Qu'est-ce que vous aimeriez faire à la Légion étrangère ?
- J'aimerais aller à Djibouti,
dans la 13ème demi-brigade de la Légion étrangère...
ou le 2ème Régiment étranger de parachutistes.
- Pour choisir ce régiment ?
- Parce que c'est le meilleur régiment de parachutistes du monde.
- Connaissez-vous le salaire d'un légionnaire ?
- Non, Monsieur.
- C'est environ 1 000 euros par mois.
- Oui, Monsieur, je serais plus qu'heureux avec ça.
- C'est suffisant pour toi ?
- Oui, Monsieur.
Plus que suffisant !
Le 2ème entretien, cette fois-ci avec un psychologue.
- As-tu déjà eu des problèmes avec la police ?
- Oui, Monsieur.
- Quels problèmes ?
- J'ai eu un problème...
il y a 2 ans pour défendre mon ami dans une bagarre.
Il y avait deux types, mon ami était ivre...
Je suis sorti de la voiture avec une batte de base-ball
et j'ai cogné sur les deux types et j'ai été arrêté pour agression.
- Tu as fait de la prison ?
- Oui, Monsieur.
- Combien de temps ?
- Un an.
J'ai fait de nombreuses erreurs dans le passé.
J'ai pris de mauvaises décisions
et je vais en prendre de bonnes, maintenant.
J'ai juste besoin d'une seconde chance.
Je sais que la Légion fera de moi un homme meilleur.
- Quels sont tes défauts et tes qualités ?
- Parfois, je suis un peu vif,
je veux que les choses soient faites très vite.
- Impulsif ?
- Oui, Monsieur.
- Liénard !
- Présent, mon lieutenant.
- Cache-moi tes lunettes.
C'est une manière civile comme tu les portes là.
Tu les mets dans la poche ou tu les mets sur tes yeux.
- Je vais les mettre sur mes yeux.
- Et pas de manière Pink Floyd.
Voilà. Assieds-toi.
Qu'est-ce qui te plaît, ici ?
- La hiérarchie militaire.
- Et qu'est-ce qui te plaît pas, ici ?
- Rien. - Y a forcément quelque chose qui te plaît pas.
- Bah, peut-être les candidats un petit peu laxistes.
- Pourquoi tu viens à la Légion étrangère ?
- Pour retrouver la vie militaire
et par la même occasion, pourquoi pas,
effectuer des missions à l'extérieur.
- Pourquoi tu veux faire des missions ?
- Faut pas se cacher la face, aussi pour l'argent et...
Mais aussi pour voir un petit peu du pays et...
- Est-ce que tu as une question à poser ?
- Non, lieutenant.
- Tu peux disposer.
- Merci, lieutenant.
- A ton avis, quels seraient tes principaux défauts ?
Qu'est-ce que tu aimerais améliorer, modifier,
si t'en avais la possibilité ?
- Des fois, on me reproche d'être autoritaire,
ce qui peut être une qualité pour ici,
mais à l'extérieur, on me le reproche.
Sinon... - C'est-à-dire, autoritaire ?
Trop franc, trop direct ? - Ouais, je mâche pas forcément mes mots.
Je dis ce que je pense.
Ca évite d'avoir des sous-entendus ou des quiproquos.
Sinon, un petit peu...
Je vais pas dire maniaque, mais plus très organisé.
- Ca se voit.
- Ah bon ? - Oui.
- Je sais pas. - T'as un caractère consciencieux très élevé
donc le côté méticuleux, pointilleux, ressort.
- Vous voyez, j'invente pas.
- Même côté maniaque.
Oui, effectivement.
Maniaque du rangement et autres.
- Je me suis amélioré.
- Lorsque t'es en groupe, ça se passe comment, habituellement ?
T'es plutôt du genre...
- Je suis très sociable.
- T'es plutôt du genre leader, du genre suiveur,
du genre à l'écoute ou un peu en retrait, un peu en réserve ?
- Non, jamais en réserve, toujours...
Plus souvent en avant, en fait.
Si je connais le domaine, je vais mettre en avant ce que je connais
justement pour que les autres puissent en profiter.
Après 2 semaines d'observation,
d'entretiens et d'enquêtes sur le passé de ces candidats,
les responsables du recrutement vont décider
de ceux qu'ils vont garder.
Chaque année, la Légion doit recruter plus d'un millier d'hommes.
La réunion doit rester secrète.
Dans quelques minutes, le lieutenant va annoncer les résultats.
- Si vous prenez pas votre initiative, je dirai peut-être :
"Ne rigole pas, ne rigole pas, ne rigole pas, ne rigole pas".
Le caporal-chef Ordon est là pour que tout soit nickel chrome.
- Y a rien de drôle là-dedans, mon garçon.
Présent ? - Présent !
- Présent ?
- Présent !
- Mon...
- Lieutenant ! - Lieutenant.
- Repos pour tout le monde.
C'est quoi, ça ? Rasé ?
Non ! - Oui. - Quoi, non ? Oui. C'est quoi, ça ?
Allez vous raser.
Rapidement.
Pareil.
Allez vous raser.
Un légionnaire, il est rasé de près.
C'est que les pionniers qui ont le droit de porter la barbe.
Pour l'instant, vous êtes loin d'être des pionniers.
Donc vos visages sont nickel chrome.
Hein ? Les yeux clairs, visages bien rasés.
Vous êtes propres, impeccables, comme tous les légionnaires.
Donc c'est la dernière fois, hein,
que je fais la remarque et que je suis obligé de vérifier.
Comme pour les enfants. Vous êtes des grands garçons,
vous savez très bien ce qu'il faut faire et comment il faut faire.
Repos !
Réfléchissez déjà,
tout à l'heure, quand le lieutenant va annoncer les résultats,
pour les mecs qui seront sélectionnés,
est-ce que vous êtes capables de faire les 5 ans
avec honneur et fidélité ?
Allez, vous avez 5 minutes.
- Tu sais ce qui va se passer, maintenant ?
- Non, je suis inquiet.
J'espère avoir réussi.
Je me pose beaucoup de questions,
Il s'est passé tellement de choses !
- Tu penses avoir tes chances ?
- Je sais que je peux le faire, mais on ne sait jamais.
- C'est le grand jour.
- Vous êtes confiant ?
- On essaie.
Faut pas partir défaitiste.
Encore quelques minutes.
- Allez, pour la session.
- Résultats des commissions.
Jakov !
Allez, ici ! Réveille-toi !
Qu'est-ce qu'on a dit tout à l'heure ? T'as rien compris, toi !
Rien. Mets-toi au garde à vous, là ! - Danic !
- Présent, mon lieutenant ! - Voilà !
Allez, action ! A côté.
Allez, au garde à vous. - Ibov.
- Présent, mon lieutenant !
- Allez ! Allez, au garde à vous.
Lève la tête.
- Allez, go !
- Allez, colle.
- Lim. - Présent, lieutenant !
- Action.
A droite, ceux qui sont retenus.
Parmi eux, Lim, le Californien.
A gauche, les recalés.
Parmi eux, Liénard.
- Je reviendrai, y a pas de souci.
- Vous êtes déçu ?
- Non parce que je m'y attendais un petit peu.
- Je ne suis pas un p*tain de moniteur de scouts.
Je suis caporal-chef à la Légion étrangère.
On est à la Légion étrangère,
je donne les ordres, vous êtes militaires, vous exécutez.
Je suis ici et je laisse pas partir au régiment,
là où y a mes frères d'armes qui sont en action,
quelqu'un qui n'en a rien à foutre de la Légion et de la France.
Vous allez voir vite fait comment je vais trouver les spécialistes.
Dalmatis !
- Présent, caporal-chef.
- Danic ! - Présent, caporal-chef !
- Horn ! - Présent, caporal-chef !
- Lim ! - Présent, caporal-chef !
- Tous les matelas, il faut les poser, et toutes les couvertures, vous me les
pliez correctement avec soin !
Bougez, bougez, bougez, bougez !
Maintenant, vous allez courir, je vous le dis déjà !
Allez !
Allez, allez, allez, allez, allez !
Chef de chambre !
Regarde ici la trace de cirage.
Allez, active-toi ! Parce que toi, tu es en train de regrouper tes p*tain d'
affaires. Et ça, ce sont tes hommes.
Allez !
Si vous n'avez plus rien à faire,
salle d'instruction et vous vous asseyez !
- C'est un gros problème pour vous de ne pas parler français ?
- Oui, c'est un gros problème parce que tout est confus,
je ne comprends rien
et je dois apprendre le français le plus vite possible.
- C'est un rêve de devenir légionnaire ?
- Oh, oui !
J'ai envie de faire quelque chose de ma vie.
Beaucoup de gens gaspillent leur temps à ne rien faire de leur vie.
- Etes-vous prêt à mourir for la Légion ou pour la France ?
- Oui, je suis prêt à mourir pour la France parce que...
c'est ma faute, je me suis attiré de nombreux problèmes aux Etats-Unis.
Personne ne m'a donné de seconde chance,
et aujourd'hui, j'ai une opportunité
et je sens que je devrai beaucoup à la France...
si la France me laisse devenir un soldat.
Je serai redevable à la France, quoi qu'il arrive.
La Légion étrangère a été créée il y a presque deux siècles.
La mémoire, la tradition, le rituel.
Les nouveaux vont recevoir leur lettre d'engagement
dans le musée d'Aubagne.
- 2ème section,
rassemblez-vous pour la remise des contrats au complet.
- A vos ordres, Lieutenant !
- Repos.
Engagé volontaire Lim.
- Présent, mon lieutenant.
- Engagé volontaire Jakov.
- Présent, lieutenant.
- Engagé volontaire Vafaina.
- Présent, mon lieutenant.
- Ecoutez-moi.
Vous pouvez devenir légionnaires.
Le légionnaire n'est pas stupide.
Le légionnaire est intelligent.
Deux, le légionnaire est physique !
Il est physique, il court,
il fait des tractions, il monte à la corde.
Il est fort.
Le légionnaire, il est fort.
Trois, le légionnaire est un bon camarade.
Bon camarade.
Ici, on se souvient.
On se souvient des légionnaires morts au combat.
36 000 morts depuis sa création en 1831.
En 181 ans d'existence, la Légion a été de toutes les guerres.
Quelques unes des plus grandes batailles,
Sébastopol, Narvik, Diên Biên Phu, Kolwezi.
En 1863, au Mexique, lors du siège de Camerone,
65 légionnaires affrontent 2 000 soldats mexicains.
Les 5 derniers légionnaires valides acceptent de se rendre
à la condition de pouvoir soigner leurs blessés
et de conserver leurs armes.
La légende était née, la Légion n'abandonne jamais les siens.
Cette troupe d'élite forte de 7 600 hommes
est capable d'intervenir à tout moment
dans les points chauds de la planète.
Il y a eu le Tchad, le Liban, la Yougoslavie
et, à partir de 2001,
l'Afghanistan.
La base de Tora, une FOB en américain, une base avancée.
Les Français l'ont installée dans un ancien fortin russe
qui contrôle la vallée d'Uzbin.
Les talibans empruntent cette vallée pour aller du Pakistan à Kaboul.
Pour eux, c'est la route stratégique
dans leur lutte contre le pouvoir en place
et contre les forces alliées qui le soutiennent.
C'est à Sper Kunday, à quelques kilomètres d'ici,
que le 18 août 2008,
10 soldats français ont été tués par les insurgés.
La veille de notre arrivée, 4 autres soldats sont morts.
- Bon, j'ai tenu à faire cette petite cérémonie
qui se clôturera par une minute de silence
en mémoire des 4 Français qui sont décédés hier,
dont 3 qui sont décédés en Kapissa suite aux intempéries.
Un des VAB de Rouge 3 est tombé dans un fossé au niveau des gorges.
Le VAB a fait une chute de 5 m
et le caporal Chechulin,
qui était tireur arrière sur la TAP arrière du VAB,
est décédé dans l'accident en place.
En place.
Garde à vous !
Depuis 2001 et l'arrivée des troupes françaises,
40 soldats sont morts en Afghanistan.
L'Afghanistan est une terre rude.
Hormis les armées de Gengis Khan,
jamais aucun étranger n'est parvenu
à soumettre ses fières et farouches tribus.
Les légionnaires du régiment étranger de cavalerie d'Orange.
L'adjudant Reiser et le sergent Sahraoui.
Dans 2 jours, ils seront parmi les 800 hommes
qui vont mener une opération d'envergure jusqu'à Sper Kunday.
- OK !
- On vient pour faire une mission demain.
Aujourd'hui, on fait un petit tir, on revérifie les armes.
Et voilà, ça nous permet de ne pas perdre la main
si jamais on reste longtemps à l'écart.
- Couche-toi ! Couche-toi, couche-toi, couche-toi !
- OK, personne là-bas.
Monte ton tir, monte ton tir, monte ton tir.
Feu !
OK, bien vu !
Pour tous les 43, annoncez dès que prêts.
- La légion, c'est pas pour les faibles.
J'en suis sûr.
Les faibles, ils ont pas de place ici.
L'adjudant Reiser dirige une section de combat de 30 hommes,
17 nationalités différentes.
- Le premier temps d'armée est fait.
Fin de tirs, maintenant, on est sereins, on peut partir dans 2 jours,
on sait très bien qu'on peut appuyer quelqu'un.
OK, tout le monde sera clair, toutes les armes seront réglées,
il n'y aura pas de problème.
L'opération commence la nuit.
La stratégie de l'état major :
transporter par hélicoptère des légionnaires sur les crêtes
qui pourront sécuriser l'avancée des troupes au sol
et aussi empêcher la fuite des
insurgés.
C'est la nuit également
que les troupes préparent l'entrée en action
des drones d'observation, ces petits avions téléguidés
munis de caméras thermiques très puissantes.
Ces drones sont efficaces de nuit comme de jour.
Ils vont surveiller le lieu des opérations,
à une vingtaine de kilomètres de leur base.
Chacun de ces drones coûte plus d'un million d'euros.
Celui-ci va survoler la piste jusqu'à Sper Kunday
et retransmettre en direct les images qu'il filme.
Dans 4 heures, un autre le
relaiera.
Dans la lumière du petit matin, au sol, nous avançons avec la section
de l'adjudant Reiser et le sergent Sahraoui.
- Y a des risques d'attaque, là, ce matin ?
- Oui, la possibilité existe partout.
Le danger est partout.
Le paysan qui fait sa vie ou le nomade,
il peut se transformer en insurgé redoutable qui tire.
Après, il se cache avec l'armement.
Déjà, les services de renseignement afghans,
ils se méfient trop de ces gens-là.
C'est comme ça, là.
Avec des moyens comme ça, ils transportent tout des pays voisins.
Regardez de mon côté,
c'est un endroit propice pour une bonne embuscade.
Pour nous, c'est pas bon.
Pour eux, c'est idéal.
C'est l'idéal.
Tous les soldats de la coalition
connaissent les images de la propagande des insurgés,
depuis la fabrication artisanale des mines jusqu'aux attentats.
Sous chaque mètre de piste,
il peut y avoir un explosif prêt à sauter,
comme celui-ci, filmé depuis un blindé américain.
La section Reiser avance avec prudence.
Nous sommes en 1re ligne.
- Vous, vous en avez déjà tué, des insurgés ?
- Le plaisir, c'est pas de tuer des insurgés.
Le plaisir, c'est de faire son travail correctement, son devoir.
- C'est ce qu'on vous apprend à la Légion ?
- Oui. Ils sont patients.
Et on respecte l'ennemi vaincu.
La section prend position
sur la zone où elle doit installer ses canons de 20 mm
pour protéger les troupes qui suivent.
Devant nous, les démineurs.
Lorsque les démineurs ont clarifié le passage,
les véhicules avancent de nouveau.
- C'est nous qui montons ici parce que tous ces colis,
y a que nous qui pouvons les traiter, avec le canon bas.
Nous sommes à environ 1 km du village de Sper Kunday.
L'adjudant Reiser est aux aguets.
- Le risque premier, c'était l'embuscade des mines, des IED,
on y est passés après.
Maintenant, le risque, c'est des infiltrations d'insurgés
qui seraient là pour nous harceler puis repartiraient.
- Ces rochers, si les mecs, ils sont en place, déjà,
impossible de les voir.
Le seul moyen, c'est qu'ils tirent.
Des cailloux, des failles, des rochers,
ça donne de bonnes possibilités de s'infiltrer.
- Un PAX repéré, qui s'est dévoilé sur la ligne de crête
et qui s'est caché derrière un rocher en 78 340 783401.
- Ces fumiers de barbus !
- Touche pas les canons.
- Là, vous êtes prêts ouvrir le feu ?
- Ah oui, prêts.
Toujours prêts, même avec le capuchon, là.
Si jamais on est pris à partie, on tire et il s'envole.
Au même moment, 15 km en arrière, le poste de commandement de Tora.
- Les PAX en exfiltration vers l'ouest à partir de Sper Kunday
ont été rejoints par 2 autres individus.
- Il est possible que ce soient des gens
qui précisent notre dispositif.
Face à notre action,
ils sont en train de voir quel volume de force on a,
jusqu'où on tire les crêtes, etc.
Ca peut très bien des gens qui vont dans les champs,
puisqu'il est l'heure d'aller au travail.
Et puis ça peut être très bien des gens qui font une liaison sur...
Qui redescendent à pied à Surobi, dans la ville.
Le colonel Durieux, patron du 2e régiment étranger d'infanterie.
Il dirige les forces françaises dans toute la vallée.
Il a un surnom : "le cerveau".
- Les insurgés nous ont observés et ont pensé qu'on attaquerait ici.
Pendant toute l'opération,
le colonel Durieux va être accompagné par un colonel afghan.
Car tout ce qu'entreprennent les Français
est fait en concertation avec l'armée nationale afghane.
Au sol, 2 canons d'une portée de 40 km
prêts à toucher des regroupements d'insurgés à côté du village,
2 Gazelle, des hélicoptères de reconnaissance
qui iront vérifier les observations des
drones.
Le colonel Durieux veut rassurer la population
et montrer qu'elle peut compter sur les militaires français.
Il va donc organiser une choura,
l'assemblée traditionnelle des notables du village,
pour leur tendre la main.
Pour afficher ses intentions pacifiques,
le colonel se sépare de son gilet pare-balles.
Le chef du village, on l'appelle le Malek.
- Je suis très heureux de le voir.
Comme dans toute choura, c'est par une prière qu'il faut commencer.
Et c'est le colonel afghan qui va la mener.
- Messieurs les grandes barbes blanches et les invités,
soyez les bienvenus. Vous savez tous que l'an dernier,
y a eu un combat important où y a 10 soldats français qui sont morts.
Je sais que c'est pas les habitants de Sper Kunday
qui ont participé à l'attaque contre les soldats français.
Nous, quand on nous attaque, c'est sûr qu'on riposte,
mais sinon je fais très attention à utiliser les armes le minimum.
Et il faut dire à ceux qui prennent les armes :
"Maintenant, le moment est venu de laisser les armes."
On est prêts à parler à tout le monde.
Ma mission, c'est d'aider l'armée afghane
et de faire qu'y ait plus de guerre ici.
Parmi ces hommes, il est certain que se trouvent des talibans.
Ils sont encore nombreux dans les villages,
mais tous n'affichent pas leur ralliement aux insurgés.
Un bruit dans le ciel, les Gazelle d'observation.
Sans doute le drone a-t-il repéré quelque chose de suspect.
- Y a du renseignement qui a été donné
sur la présence d'insurgés de l'autre côté de la ligne de crête, là,
qui est pas recoupé, mais donc on préfère les mettre en vol
et puis confirmer le renseignement pour voir si, effectivement,
on voit un regroupement de l'autre côté de la ligne de crête.
Au-delà de montrer la force des alliés et d'occuper le terrain,
les autorités afghanes voulaient fouiller quelques maisons
qui pourraient servir de cache d'armes.
- La police afghane voulait fouiller dans les maisons.
Je pense que ce n'est pas le moment.
Je ne veux pas contredire mon discours
en effectuant des fouilles dans les maisons.
- J'ai dit au capitaine, au chef de l'ANP, de venir ici.
pour qu'on parle ensemble, avec vous.
- Enfin, moi, j'en ai parlé avec le colonel, je pense qu'aujourd'hui,
il faut absolument rien chercher parce qu'on a fait toute la choura
sur le thème "vous êtes les gentils,
"les méchants sont de l'autre côté, on vous fait confiance",
donc on s'en fout de trouver 5 ou 6 obus de mortier.
- Vous voulez faire annuler les fouilles ?
- Vous avez rien observé, vous ?
- Non, mis à part les quelques mouvements sur la ligne de crête,
mais sans pouvoir confirmer que c'est hostile.
La stratégie pacificatrice du colonel Durieux,
c'est aussi de distribuer quelques cadeaux,
des couvertures et des cerfs-volants pour les enfants.
*- Dragon, ici panthère, parlez.
- Panthère, ici dragon, parlez.
*- Les Gazelle ont été prises à partie par armes lourdes.
On demande l'autorisation de tirs de mortiers sur cette position.
- C'est en-dehors du cirque de Sper Kunday, correct ?
*- Affirmatif. C'est le col.
- Ils ont la position exacte ?
*- Je suis en train de préciser la position exacte
via la 3e dimension.
- Oui.
Reçu. Vous confirmez le renseignement, si on a la position exacte...
Accordé.
*- Panthère, ici dragon, reçu.
- Autoriser un tir comme ça, c'est toujours une décision lourde ?
- Ah oui. Parce qu'y a un aspect militaire,
mais y a un aspect politique dans la zone,
y a un aspect de dommages collatéraux, donc c'est toujours...
Il faut faire très attention.
Là, c'est sur une ligne de crête, donc y a personne qui y habite.
On vient de se faire tirer dessus
donc on sait que c'est une position ennemie
et c'est en-dehors de la zone d'intérêt, donc ça ne va pas porter...
Ca n'entre pas dans le dialogue que j'ai ici
avec cette population de Sper Kunday.
- Tendre la main vers la réconciliation,
et en même temps, être ferme, c'est ça, votre philosophie ?
- Ouais, il faut tendre la main vers les habitants,
mais montrer qu'on est fermes vers ceux qui cherchent...
Vers les insurgés qui, eux, cherchent au contraire
à briser toute tentative de réconciliation.
Le drone a localisé le point de départ des tirs sur les hélicoptères.
A Tora, 15 km en arrière, les canons ont été réglés.
- 2e...
C'est efficace.
Rien ne doit rester impuni.
Leurs obus de 155 mm radioguidés ne laissent aucune chance de survie
sur la surface d'un terrain de football.
- Pour le 3e, celui-là !
- Misson accomplie. Mission accomplie.
- Nous sommes de la Légion.
Si loin de nos pays
- Vers le front, nous marcherons
Pour vaincre l'ennemi.
Quelques heures plus tard, les insurgés réagissent.
- Mon gars, ils sont beaucoup, ces fils de p*te !
On apprendra ensuite qu'ils ont perdu 2 hommes, dont un commandant,
lors du bombardement de leurs positions.
Leur cible pour cette réaction le COP Rocco, à 10 km de Sper Kunday.
Un COP, c'est un poste de combat avancé.
Il est entouré de villages considérés comme ennemis.
250 légionnaires tiennent cette position, entourés par les insurgés.
Ce matin, le harcèlement continue.
Le lieutenant François assure le commandement de la garde.
- On a entendu des explosions au niveau de la position d'OP1, là,
à 500 m dans cette direction, de l'autre côté de la ligne de crête.
Pour l'instant, on sait pas ce que c'est.
Donc on va voir.
Mais au cas où, on se tient prêts sur la défense de la côte.
Pour les 4 000 soldats français stationnés en Afghanistan,
le danger, ce sont les CHICOM,
des roquettes chinoises qui peuvent être lancées
avec des tubes tout à fait artisanaux et très mobiles,
mais pas très précis.
- Message de Tango 2.
Il a vu un personnel, distance environ 200-300 m.
Pas d'arme, mais il est en train de téléphoner.
- Avons repéré un personnel à 450 m ouest de tango unité.
- Apprête-toi à tirer.
- Poste de combat, 3-2 à droite.
Visuel, je le vois.
- Il est là, il est à 150 m.
- Ah, de nouveau visuel,
il est remonté sur le plateau et il court vers le nord.
- Départ de coup.
- Pour les verts 99, pour les verts 99, a priori, départ de coup.
Départ de coup, maintenez l'observation.
- Les mecs qui sont là-haut, tu riposteras pas au FAMAS.
- P@tain !
Les coups partent, mais on ne les voit pas arriver.
- OK, 2e départ de coup.
- 2e départ !
- Rentre à l'intérieur.
Rentrez. Rentrez à l'intérieur.
On subit des tirs de 82 mm.
De mortier de 82.
Donc ils sont en train de régler et ils se...
Ca se rapproche.
Tous les personnels qui sont pas dans les bunkers,
ils sont dans les VAB, reçu ?
- Equipe 300, tu prends tout le monde dans le VAB.
Les insurgés sont en train d'ajuster leurs tirs.
- Encore un départ.
- Départ de coup.
Ca vient des...
- Ca vient de là-haut.
- Ca vient du nord-est.
On dirait que c'est derrière la montagne.
- Si ça tombe là, c'est même pas la peine.
- 354, 40 769.
- Correct.
- 2 233, correct ?
- Y a un tir de mortier qui se prépare ?
- On a autorisation de tirer des fumigènes.
Tirer des obus fumigènes pour les empêcher d'observer et de régler.
- Tu charges ici.
- T'es en automatique.
Attention ! - C'est pour qui ?
- Charge 5.
- OK.
- Feu !
Attention... Feu !
- Attention !
- C'est Verdun, là, c'est une bataille d'artilleurs.
C'est essayer de repérer l'observateur, les départs de coups
et puis tirer sur les départs de coups.
Pour l'instant, les fantassins, on est à l'abri, là.
Des obus pour créer un écran de fumée
afin d'empêcher un ennemi invisible de les voir.
Ce jour-là, les insurgés n'ont pas réussi à toucher le COP Rocco.
- 2, 3, 4, 5 !
Les candidats légionnaires qui avaient été sélectionnés à Aubagne
sont arrivés à côté de Castelnaudary.
Parmi eux, Lim.
Dans ce centre de formation, la sélection va continuer.
- 5 !
- Vous avez choisi de venir à la Légion étrangère.
Je vous félicite, c'est un choix d'homme.
Vous commencez aujourd'hui l'instruction qui durera 4 mois
et qui fera de vous des légionnaires.
Le légionnaire est un soldat d'élite.
Pour le former et l'instruire,
il faut du temps et beaucoup de travail.
Garde à vous !
Pour l'instant,
très peu sont capables de comprendre des ordres en français.
- Chine. - States of America.
- Bulgarie. - Ghana.
- Roumanie. - Ukraine.
- Brésil. - Suède.
- Mongolie. - Finlande.
- Allemagne. - Espagne.
- Croatie. - Vanuatu.
- Russie. - Pologne.
- Maroc. - Iran.
- Madagascar.
Première mise à l'épreuve : leur endurance.
- Il faut être un peu dur avec soi-même et avec tout le monde aussi.
Y a pas de pitié, on ne peut pas rester mous, faibles
ou montrer ses faiblesses aux autres.
Faut être dur
faut penser parfois par soi-même et cracher le sang pour être bon.
- C'est l'encadrement qui est là pour recadrer ces jeunes-là,
pour qu'ils se mettent bien dans l'ambiance.
Et s'ils ont pas suffisamment de mental,
eh ben, on va les aider à se pousser à aller plus loin.
C'est ça qui est important, aller plus loin, toujours plus loin.
Ca, c'est l'avenir de la Légion étrangère.
C'est pas des touristes en vacances.
- On va faire demi-tour, on va récupérer.
- Serrez !
Raccroche !
Maintenant, dernière foulée, on y va.
On n'accélère pas, on garde la cadence.
Arrête de faire ta victime.
Pour manger, y a pas de souci, hein.
Ferme ta gueule !
A la fin de leur formation, dans 4 mois, pour devenir légionnaires,
il faudra qu'ils connaissent au moins 500 mots de français.
- G, H, I, R...
- R.
- OK. - Les deux visées...
- Les deux visées... - Ne sont pas alignées.
- En bas !
En haut !
En bas !
Pendant 5 semaines, ils vont vivre en autarcie dans cette ferme,
sans aucun contact avec l'extérieur.
Une seule préoccupation : devenir des guerriers.
- Top !
Les mains comme ça...
Dépêchez-vous !
Allez, rapidement !
Allez ! Sélection naturelle !
Y a pas de place pour les faibles.
Dégoupillez !
Lancez... grenade !
- Voilà, c'est bien !
Pousse ! Pousse, pousse, pousse !
Après 15 jours d'épreuves, Lim suit le rythme,
mais il a quelques soucis avec ses mains.
Quelques soucis aussi avec le français.
- Donc aujourd'hui, tu as arraché ça.
C'est bon, c'est pas grand-chose, non ?
Sur quel obstacle tu as eu ce problème ?
Tu as fait quoi ?
Où tu as arraché ça ?
- En bas...
En haut...
- Dessus-dessous ?
Ouais ? - Oui, sergent.
- Et avant, tu n'as jamais été dans l'armée, non ?
- Pardon, j'ai jamais...
Je n'ai pas...
Je...
Je pas compris.
- Tu as pas compris. - J'ai pas compris parler.
- Ca fait mal ?
- Petit.
- Petit ? Si tu vas travailler aujourd'hui après-midi, tu mets les
gants.
OK, tu peux disposer.
- Je peux disposer ? Merci, sergent.
Vafaina est malgache.
Il a 20 ans. Et comme les autres,
il apprend une des 1res règles de la Légion, la solidarité.
- Faut que ce soit rangé comment, ça ?
- Il faut que de ce côté, il n'y ait rien qui dépasse de là.
Tout le monde a peur parce qu'après, si quelqu'un n'est pas bien,
tout le monde prend la douche froide dehors
et donc on est un peu stressés.
- Vous êtes content d'être là, vous ?
- Ouais
- Pourquoi ?
- J'aime beaucoup la Légion et comme on m'en a beaucoup parlé,
j'aimerais bien moi aussi en faire partie.
- Mais c'est un parcours difficile.
- Ouais, c'est un peu difficile, mais tout le monde va passer là,
donc il faut qu'on passe aussi par là pour être légionnaires.
- Tout doit être bien rangé, tout doit être pareil.
- Faut que ça soit carré, quoi.
Bien rangé. - C'est toujours pas bon.
Le sergent-chef chargé de cet apprentissage s'appelle Cho.
- Ils ont mal plié.
D'accord ? C'est pas pareil.
Ca, tout, bien
aligné.
Ca pue.
Rassemblement section en bas.
Effectivement, la sanction n'attend pas.
- Pour ranger quelques chaussettes, quelques tee-shirts,
quelques pantalons et quelques vestes, le résultat, c'est pas bien.
D'accord ?
- Oui, chef !
- En position.
En position.
En position. Action, là.
En haut, en bas.
En haut, en bas. En haut, en bas.
En bas !
En bas ! En haut !
Fatigués ? - Non, chef !
- En bas !
En haut !
En bas !
A la fin de la 2e semaine,
petit coup de blues pour un candidat biélorusse qui souhaite partir.
- Engagé volontaire Kastrov, 2ème compagnie.
- Donne le contrat d'engagement.
OK. Contrat d'engagement.
T'as pas trouvé ce que tu voulais chercher.
C'est normal, on n'a rien fait, encore.
D'accord ? Donc tu vas trouver, t'inquiète pas,
y a pas de souci, y a pas de problème.
En attendant, t'as signé un contrat de 5 ans.
Donc comme t'es un mec d'honneur, t'es pas un gamin, t'as 28 ans,
t'as un passé militaire,
donc la vie militaire, tu l'as déjà touchée du doigt,
et pour moi, tu t'es engagé pour faire une carrière militaire.
Donc t'es un mec sensé, les pieds sur Terre,
t'inquiète pas, ce que t'es venu chercher,
tu vas le trouver, on va te le donner, y a pas de souci.
De toute façon, y a personne qui part avant la fin de l'instruction
pour la simple et bonne raison qu'il est venu, il s'est engagé.
Donc c'est un volontaire, il fait comme tout le monde,
il suit l'instruction correctement.
Ca va lui laisser le temps largement
de se faire une idée de ce qui l'attend après.
Prends ton contrat et tu peux disposer.
Prends ton contrat.
C'est à toi, ça.
Béret sur la tête.
En fait, le candidat biélorusse
peut rejoindre la vie civile quand il le veut.
Le coup de blues touche plusieurs des apprentis légionnaires.
Tout d'un coup, l'approche de l'hiver les inquiète.
- Ils ont envie de partir à cause du froid.
Ils ont un bon physique.
Mentalement, je sais pas, mais au physique, ils sont bons.
Ils ont envie de partir.
- Toi, tu manques un petit peu de mental, en ce moment ?
- Voilà, je manque un petit peu de mental.
Beaucoup de.
.. Ca fait 2-3 jours que je pense beaucoup à partir.
- C'est pas que je veuille partir, mais ma famille me manque.
C'est dur.
Il faut être très costaud mentalement.
- Dehors, il fait très froid.
J'ai faim. Pas de cigarettes. Je pense que je serais mieux à la maison avec ma
petite amie.
- Parfois, je me sens coupable
car je n'ai pas dit à ma famille que je venais ici.
Mais je sais que dans 3 semaines,
je vais les appeler pour leur dire que je suis vivant.
Ce jour-là, une marche de 8 km avec des sacs de 15 kg.
Vafaina, le Malgache, n'avait jamais vu la neige.
- C'est pas trop compliqué de marcher comme ça, dans la neige ?
- Chez nous, y a la boue, c'est un peu comme la boue.
Sauf que la boue, ça colle, mais ça, ça colle pas, ça
glisse.
J'ai les gants pleins de neige, là, les mains gelées.
Après, on va faire des murs.
Je sais pas comment je vais y arriver, mais je vais me dém*rder.
- Allez !
Je suis un guerrier parce qu'y a beaucoup de trucs.
auxquels on essaie de résister alors que la force n'est pas trop là,
mais il faut qu'on résiste.
- Tiens.
Les bras à l'avant.
Ca...
Tu sais nager ? - Oui, sergent.
- Ils commencent à s'endurcir, les hommes, là ?
- Ouais, ça fait partie de la formation.
C'est une formation.
- C'est une formation qui est dure ?
- Non, c'est plus mental que physique.
Y en a quelques-uns qui tiennent bien.
Y en a d'autres qui...
Mais ce qui compte beaucoup, c'est la volonté.
- C'est bon !
Débarque, débarque, débarque !
Allez, allez, allez ! - C'est le froid et la fatigue un peu aussi, qui
commencent à faire, et puis, bah, moralement, quand on s'éloigne des amis,
de la famille, quand même, au bout d'un moment, on y pense,
on voudrait passer un coup de fil, mais on attend.
- A la Légion, y a des choses que vous avez pas le droit de faire ?
- Ouais.
- Quoi, par exemple ? - Quand on s'engage, on n'a pas droit de se marier avant 5
ans.
Pas de voiture pendant 5 ans,
le téléphone portable juste à la fin de l'instruction.
C'est...
Voilà, c'est... Et chaque truc qu'on veut faire,
il faut qu'on demande l'autorisation à nos chefs
ou au-dessus de nous, quoi, au capitaine.
Mais bon, voilà.
- C'est un petit peu pesant, parfois ?
- Pour l'instant, non.
On n'a pas eu l'occasion de tester, encore.
Mais bon, c'est tout.
On savait les conditions avant de rentrer à la Légion.
- La ferme, c'est un peu le retour dans la vie d'avant
pour nous enlever notre vie civile.
Comme ça, tu pourras te dém*rder dans des endroits
où tu te trouveras en difficulté, tout ça,
tu pourras te dém*rder à chaque fois.
C'est ça. Dans la vie civile, t'as l'habitude de manger à ta faim et tout.
Et dans la ferme, y aura pas ça,
y a pas des chocolats, tout ça, du Coca...
Si un jour, tu pars à la guerre,
y aura pas ça pendant les coups de feu.
- Vous, vous êtes prêt à risquer votre vie pour la Légion ?
- Ouais, moi, je suis prêt.
- Pourquoi ?
- Parce que...
Je me suis engagé, je veux changer de vie.
J'ai déjà réglé ma tête.
Quoi qu'il se passe, je suis...
Je résisterai.
- Il est passé au-dessus de toi, là ?
- Ouais, j'ai entendu.
Je t'ai dit, j'ai entendu 12 coups.
J'ai entendu "bim", et après, m*rde, il est passé.
- Je pensais que c'était un tir de mortier.
J'ai pensé à un CHICOM.
- On va sortir.
- On va sur le blindage, y a encore des tirs de mortier.
- Oh !
C'était tout près ! - OK !
Préparez-vous par 6 !
- Allez, préparez 6 !
- 3...
Feu ! - Vous arrivez à voir ce qui se passe, là ?
- Oui, j'observe où ça tombe pour faire des réglages en plus.
- C'est parti, on envoie la pierre !
- Feu !
- Au mortier !
Au mortier ! - Là, je pense qu'ils vont être calmés parce que c'est la 2ème fois
en 3 jours et on a riposté à l'artillerie tout de suite, là,
donc on va envoyer la purée avec le mortier lourd, je pense.
Là, ils sont sur un aspirateur à obus.
On appelle ça un aspirateur à obus en tactique.
C'est une position haute, dominante,
à partir de laquelle on voit très bien,
mais que l'artillerie traite très facilement en permanence.
Donc voilà.
Là, on entend les avions, actuellement. - Comment savoir si y a des blessés ou
des morts de l'autre côté ?
- Là, c'est juste une reconnaissance aérienne qui peut nous le dire.
Parce que là, c'est assez loin.
C'est quand même à 5 km.
- On a essayé de traiter l'objectif.
On sait pas pour l'instant s'il y a des blessés ou des morts,
si on a tué personne.
- Je demande l'autorisation d'effectuer un tir de 2 coups explo
sur les mêmes éléments que tout à l'heure.
- Vert, ici Griffon.
Vous avez pas d'observations sur la demande de tir, correct ?
C'est juste un harcèlement, correct ?
- Affirmatif, c'est pour éviter
qu'ils reviennent se mettre en observation.
*- Vert, ici Griffon.
- Griffon, ici Vert, parlez.
Tir demandé refusé.
- Bien reçu.
- C'est parfois pas facile d'imposer son point de vue ?
- Moi, je suis pas là pour imposer mon point de vue.
Je rends compte. Et puis je rends compte de différentes possibilités tactiques,
et puis après, c'est le chef qui fait son
choix.
Pour ce soir, y a une menace encore forte d'attaque sur la COP.
Donc attention aux balles perdues.
C'est pour ça que je vous dis ne grenouillez pas dans la COP.
Quand ça tire sur la COP, vous vous mettez sous blindage,
vous vous planquez et vous attendez les ordres, d'accord ?
Ca sert à rien de s'en prendre une bêtement sur la COP
alors qu'on n'était même pas dans un poste de combat
en train de tirer. Je pense maintenant qu'on riposte massivement, c'est bien...
Maintenant, il faut toucher. Tant qu'on n'aura pas touché,
qu'on n'aura pas fait mal à un ou deux chefs insurgés
et qu'on n'en aura pas mis quelques-uns au tapis,
les conneries, elles vont continuer sur la COP, OK ?
- OK, bonne soirée.
- Salaam aleikoum.
Là, je vais commencer une petite choura avec le malek
et quelques barbes blanches, dans la maison du malek.
- Salaam aleikoum.
- Lieutenant Ponticelli.
Pour gagner du temps, on va faire descendre le véhicule.
Il faut faire reculer, là, les mecs,
parce qu'y a des enfants et des femmes.
Donc vous les faites reculer,
ils restent le long de ce mouvement de terrain, là.
C'est bon ?
- Ouais, c'est bon.
- On pense que la sécurité est en train de se dégrader dans la zone.
D'accord ?
Y a eu attaque le soir sur les éléments débarqués,
y a eu attaque sur la COP avec des tirs de CHICOM et des tirs de RPG.
Avant-hier, y a eu 13 obus de mortier
qui sont tombés sur les postes ANA, à proximité de la COP.
Enfin, tôt ce matin, y a encore eu des coups de feu qui sont partis
et y a 10 hommes à pied qui ont été vus
en train de marcher à hauteur de Kabratu.
- Oui, j'ai entendu dire qu'il y avait des insurgés à Kabratu.
Personnellement, je ne les ai pas vus.
- L'ANA respecte les gens, ne fouille pas les maisons.
Maintenant il faut pas mentir.
Et le capitaine de l'ANA, il avait été très clair, il avait dit :
"Si la prochaine fois,
"y a des gens qui nous tirent à partir des maisons,
"on détruira les maisons."
D'accord ?
Donc il faut pas nous mentir. On sait qu'y a des gens, ils jouent, ils
accueillent les insurgés.
- Cela devient un vrai problème pour nous.
On les voit préparer leurs opérations tout près d'ici.
Nous, les maleks, on n'a aucun pouvoir.
- Jusqu'à présent, on avait des bons rapports avec la population.
Ce qui est sûr, c'est que la dernière fois qu'ils nous ont attaqués,
ils sont passés par ce village, donc voilà.
Il peut être hostile de temps en temps
si y a des insurgés qui viennent dans la zone.
Si y en a pas, la population ne va pas nous tirer dessus comme ça.
- Ponticelli, rafale à l'est, là.
Donc les PAX de chez vous, là, vous écartez le dispositif.
On va garder que les PAX nécessaires
pour la sécurisation de la zone de distribution.
- Rafale entendue à l'ouest.
Donc je demande notamment à 23-21
d'être particulièrement attentif sur l'observation.
Là, y en a pour combien de temps, là, pour distribuer ?
- C'est fait en 10 minutes, un quart d'heure.
- OK, vous prenez en compte le Malek avec Farid,
qu'il se perde pas dans les...
- L'ambiance, elle est spéciale, ici ?
- Moi, y a...
Il faut faire attention parce qu'y a beaucoup de monde.
Bon, y a l'ANP en haut qui contrôle en faisant des check points,
y a l'ANA qui est dans le talweg qui peut contrôler aussi.
Donc le risque, comme, y a du monde,
faut pas qu'y ait de suicide bomber ou de choses comme ça.
- Ce village-là, il a l'air acquis aux insurgés pour l'instant ?
- C'est difficile à dire. Je pense que dans tous les villages,
y a une partie de la population qui est favorable aux insurgés,
une partie qui est plus favorable à la force,
et puis une grosse partie qui est fluctuante, on va dire,
qui va se rallier au plus fort ou qui va se rallier à celui qui défend le mieux
ses intérêts.
- Et là, vous pensez que ça va être utile, ce genre de geste,
ou c'est illusoire ?
- Non, tout à fait. C'est utile.
C'est utile de faire ça parce que ça nous permet, déjà,
d'avoir un contact avec la population.
Et ils voient qu'on n'est pas là uniquement pour des actions armées.
- Allez, 40, départ immédiat.
- Voilà, 5 572.
5-5-7-2, 5 572.
- C'est bon.
- Tu mets...
*- Correct.
Je suis en mesure de l'envoyer.
Est-ce que vous avez encore besoin de l'ANP en bas ?
- Affirmatif.
Depuis tout à l'heure, on observe
et j'ai mis la surveillance dans leur direction.
*- Bien reçu.
- On attend les maleks pour commencer la choura.
- Là, y a un risque d'être attaqué par les insurgés ?
- Ben, a priori, ils ont l'écoute des ...
A priori, ils ont entendu qu'ils se préparent
et qu'ils ont regroupé les munitions et roquettes pour nous attaquer.
On attend.
- Ca vous fait peur ?
- Non. Non.
- Vous, vous connaissez pas la peur, à la Légion ?
- Si, tout le monde a peur, mais il faut savoir maîtriser.
P*tain, je le vois pas, ce mongole.
- Vous voyez, là ?
- Ah oui, il bouge, là, oui.
Sur la ligne de crête, carrément.
*- Chargez dans la région
et le but des insurgés serait de ne pas nous laisser repartir.
D'accord ?
- Ils veulent pas nous laisser partir.
Ils veulent qu'on reste ici.
Les ennemis. - Je pense qu'ils vont nous attaquer.
C'est possible. Ca bouge dans tous les sens, ils voient des PAX dans tous les
sens,
au nord, au nord-ouest, au nord-est, un peu partout.
Ils se déplacent par 6, par 5.
- Il y a des talibans ici, autour ?
- Non, il n'y a pas de talibans.
- Hier, il y en avait.
Hier soir.
- Ils sont partis hier soir.
- Par là ?
- Venez, je vais vous montrer.
Là-bas !
Derrière le grand arbre !
- Qu'est-ce qu'on fait ?
- Fais demi-tour !
Vas-y !
Tourne par là-bas ! - Couche-toi là.
Couche-toi ici. Attends !
- Recule, recule !
- Là !
Là ! - OK.
- Combien on a d'hommes ici ?
- Deux. - Préparez encore 5 obus, là !
- Abritez-vous !
Personne ici ! - Allez, derrière, derrière.
- Derrière !
Et restez là.
- Correct.
*- Reçu.
C'est vous-même qui avez réglé le tir.
- Correct.
- OK, préparez 6 coups !
Préparez 6 coups en plus !
OK, pareil là !
Récupère les éléments chez lui.
Abritez-vous !
Abritez-vous ! Derrière moi. Abritez-vous.
Allez, feu !
Donne du gaz, donne du gaz !
Deux d'un coup !
Feu !
Baissez-vous tous !
J'ai un visuel.
100 m à droite plus haut sur la ligne de crête, les départs de coups.
- Relevez !
- Là où ça tire, là !
Là où ils tirent maintenant !
Dessous ! Préparez 6 !
- Feu !
- Ca fume, hein !
- Nettoyez toutes les charges !
Ramassez toutes les charges, les cocons vides.
Allez, vite fait !
Vite fait ! Nettoyez la zone, on sait jamais à quelle heure on va décrocher !
- Allez, nettoyage de la zone !
Grattez les tubes !
On a tiré un peu au mortier.
On a tiré aux armes lourdes. Maintenant, y a des hélicos qui arrivent.
- Les hélicos, c'est les Tigre, là ?
- Ouais, c'est les Tigre, on peut voir ici, là.
- Vous avez eu chaud.
Ca vous fait du bien de tirer un petit peu sur l'ennemi ?
- Ils nous tirent dessus, on leur tire dessus, c'est tout.
Tenez, c'est les jumelles de chez nous, OK ?
Vous voyez la ligne de crête juste devant nous ?
A priori, à partir de là, y a quelqu'un qui nous a tiré dessus.
Vous faites la couverture à partir de là pour nous, au cas où.
- OK. - C'est bon ?
*- Affirmatif, c'est embarqué.
- On y va !
- Allez, allez, n'oubliez rien !
N'oubliez rien ! - On bouge, on bouge, on bouge !
Bienvenue en Afghanistan !
- Bienvenue en Afghanistan.
*- On en a repéré deux au total.
- Vise à droite !
Voilà !
- Hélicoptère
! - Y a un personnel derrière.
Y a une tête qui sort.
- Chouffe bien par là, OK ?
Si ça se trouve, les enc*lés, ils vont passer par derrière.
- Vous pensez que c'est terminé ou...
- C'est pas sûr.
C'est pas sûr.
Si ça se trouve, on reçoit encore des tirs du nord, c'est possible.
- Ca vous fait quoi de...
Vous avez des montées d'adrénaline ou ça va ?
- Bien sûr qu'on a des montées d'adrénaline.
Bien sûr qu'on a des montées d'adrénaline, pour tout le monde.
- Pourquoi ? - Bah, ça ricoche à côté des oreilles, l'adrénaline, elle monte.
- Vous avez peur de mourir, vous ?
- Non.
Je crois en Dieu, j'ai pas peur de mourir.
- Préparez-vous pour la poussière !
- Voilà du boudin !
Voilà du boudin !
Pour les Alsaciens, les Suisses
et les Lorrains !
Pour les Belges, y en a plus, pour les Belges, y en a plus !
Ce sont des tireurs au cul !
Pour les Belges, y en a plus...
- Ce soir, c'est leur 1er cadeau de Noël, c'est une housse à képi.
Parce que bientôt, ils vont recevoir leur képi blanc, évidemment.
Et c'est une lampe parce que faut toujours savoir où on va,
maintenant qu'on est dans la Légion.
Ouh là là, t'es plus grand que moi, toi !
Joyeux Noël à toi.
Bon, Vafaina, joyeux Noël à toi.
Joyeux Noël.
- Réveillez-vous, les garçons ! C'est pas fini.
C'est pas parce qu'il neige que c'est la fin du monde.
Repos.
- 2ème section, garde à vous !
Repos. Garde à vous !
Bon, les gars, vous allez arrêter de nous casser les pieds
avec vos histoires de relationnel, là,
tous les 2, là, les 2 champions du monde, les boxeurs.
Venez ici, là.
Alors toi, t'es même pas foutu d'être en tenue !
C'est grave. Voilà.
Alors ici, on a quoi ? 2 champions du monde.
2 abrutis qui ont pas compris que s'ils se tapent sur la gueule,
eh ben, ils tapent pas sur l'ennemi.
Voilà. Donc ça, je veux plus voir ça à la section.
Lim, récite-moi le code d'honneur.
- Légionnaire,
tu es un volontaire servant la France avec honneur et fidélité.
Chaque légionnaire est ton frère d'arme.
- Stop !
Répète. - Chaque légionnaire est ton frère d'arme.
- T'as compris ? - Oui, mon lieutenant.
- Phelps. - Légionnaire, tu...
Légionnaire, Tu es un volontaire servant la France avec honneur et fidélité.
- Ouais.
- Chaque légionnaire est ton frère d'arme.
- Répète !
- Tout le monde a compris ? - Oui, mon lieutenant !
- OK, maintenant, on va les attacher comme 2 frères.
Hein ? Voilà.
Et ça durera le temps qu'il faut, jusqu'à ce que vous ayez compris,
espèces de crétins !
Allez !
Vous allez voir, le chef va s'occuper de vous, là.
Vous allez voir le chef tout de suite.
- Viens ici.
Hop.
Tiens ça.
- Vous allez apprendre à vous aimer.
Ce sera plus constructif que de se cartonner la bouche,
t'as compris ? - Oui, mon lieutenant.
- Et toi ?
- Oui, mon lieutenant.
- Lâche.
- Y a eu une altercation entre les deux, là, ce matin.
Voilà. Bon, la raison, je la connais pas, ça m'intéresse pas.
Ce qui m'intéresse, c'est qu'ils aient bien compris qu'on est là,
on va tous dans la même direction.
Si pour eux, c'est pas clair,
à l'issue de la punition, ça va le devenir.
- Voilà, allez.
C'est parti !
C'est parti ! Allez, du rythme !
Du rythme !
- Faut m'occuper tout le monde.
Les mecs, ils vont pas rester à sécher comme ça debout.
Voilà.
Les 2, là, tu leur donnes une mission particulière
et tu mets un caporal avec.
- Tu le remplaces.
Mission pour toi : surveiller les 2 binômes qui sont attachés.
Et eux, ils déneigent l'escalier.
Tu restes avec eux !
- A la Légion, y a pas de bagarres.
C'est amis !
C'est amis, compris, gringo ?
- Oh là, pourquoi vous vous arrêtez, là ?
Qui a dit de s'arrêter ?
Oh là ! Un genou à terre !
Un genou à terre.
- C'est pas un peu une brimade ?
- Pas du tout. - Une brimade...
On leur a pas mis un boulet au pied,
on les a pas habillés en tenue de taulard.
C'est juste qu'ils comprennent
qu'on est là pour aller tous dans la même direction.
Si on a des différends, on met les petits plats dans les grands et...
Et puis on remplit la mission.
On peut pas non plus forcément s'entendre avec tout le monde,
mais y a des façons de régler les problèmes.
Bon, on sait bien que le légionnaire est un peu bagarreur.
Ca, c'est son état d'esprit.
Mais il faut pas se tromper d'objectif.
- Est-ce que t'as compris ?
Oui ou non ?
Voilà, récupère 2 seaux et en avant.
Reste sur le chemin. - Pourquoi tu pleures ?
Qu'est-ce qu'il se passe ?
Tu t'es fait mal ?
Explique-moi. Qu'est-ce qu'il se passe ?
- Je ne sens plus mes mains.
- Elles sont gelées.
Qu'est-ce qu'il y a, Romanu ?
- Je ne sens plus mes mains !
- Ca fait mal ?
Allez, viens, Romanu.
Tu peux marcher ? Arrête de pleurer, là !
Viens. Oh !
Il a mangé, ce matin ?
- Très chaud !
Très chaud !
- Assieds-toi. - Ouais, c'est bon !
Arrête de pleurer, hein !
C'est pas un problème, calme-toi.
Calme-toi, hein.
Calme-toi.
- Je sens mes mains quand il y a de l'eau chaude sans arrêt.
Mais quand il n'y en a pas assez, mes mains font pschitt, pschitt,
le mal passe à travers mes mains et remonte.
C'est vraiment très dur, très, très dur.
J'ai jamais eu ça avant. Je vois tout noir ! Je vois tout noir !
Je vois tout noir !
- C'est bon, c'est pas grave.
C'est pas grave. C'est pas grave.
Ouvre tes yeux !
Ouvre les yeux ! Ouvre !
Ca va mieux ! Voilà, ouvre tes yeux.
Regarde-moi, regarde-moi.
Regarde-moi.
C'est pas grave, hein.
Le médecin, il va te donner des médicaments.
Après, tu vas faire la marche du képi blanc.
- Oui. - Voilà, c'est bien.
- PLS, inconscient.
- Comment ?
- Turon, PLS, inconscient.
OK, tu restes ici tranquille, tu montes
là-haut.
- Comme ça, t'es confortable ?
Hein ? - Oui, chef. - Ouvre tes yeux.
Non, les yeux. Là.
Ferme pas les yeux, d'accord ?
Reste comme ça.
T'as froid ? Froid ?
T'as mangé, ce matin ? Voilà.
Tu peux marcher ? Marcher ?
- Non. - Non ?
Tu sens tes jambes ?
Tu sens ?
Là ? - Oui, oui.
- Mal ? - Mal.
- D'accord.
C'est bon. D'accord.
Doucement, doucement, doucement.
- Voilà.
Si vous voyez des camarades qui vont pas bien, vous dites :
"Caporal-chef, caporal, camarade comme ci, comme ça."
Faut pas laisser les camarades, "ouch",
et après, c'est trop tard, compris, ça ?
Compris, ça ?
- Oui, caporal-chef !
C'est fini les mentalités civiles,
on a fait un coup de réglage et en avant, daï, daï.
C'est comme ça, les gars, OK ?
Je vous l'ai dit, la vie, c'est pas facile.
Vous avez choisi un très beau métier,
mais c'est très difficile aussi.
Il faut continuer, les gars.
Vous verrez, plus tard, vous regretterez pas, OK ?
De toute façon, dans la vie, il faut avoir aucun regret, les gars.
Faut jamais rien regretter.
Faut vivre à 200 à l'heure, à 260.
- Tu me dis quand c'est bon, hein.
Il peut pas manger tout seul, donc il faut l'aider.
Je suis content de le faire.
C'est comme si c'était mon devoir de le faire, hein.
Ca, par contre, il a mal aux mains, mais il mange toujours autant.
- 1...
- 2...
- 3.
- Allez, allez, ça avance bien là, continuez !
- Je me sens bien, c'est seulement mes mains.
Je peux bouger ces deux doigts un petit peu.
J'espère qu'ils vont pouvoir m'aider à l'hôpital.
Les personnel va me prendre en charge dans très peu de temps.
Je crois qu'ils vont m'envoyer de l'électricité sur les doigts.
Pour les réveiller.
- Je suis toujours prêt !
- Le lieutenant m'a donné des gants pour protéger mes mains contre le froid.
Très bien.
- Pas trop fort, mais je vais y arriver.
Il faut serrer les dents, avancer jusqu'à la fin.
- Je vous rappelle l'importance de la marche képi blanc.
Celui qui n'arrive pas à la fin de la marche, il n'a pas son képi blanc.
Dans les groupes, y en a qui sont plus ou moins en forme,
eh ben, il faut les aider.
Donc je compte sur vous pour que ça se passe bien
et que tout le monde arrive au bout.
- Allez, on y va.
Qu'est-ce qu'il se passe ?
- Sergent...
- Allez, on avance là-bas, jusqu'en haut.
Allez. Allez, pose ton
sac.
Tu peux marcher ou tu peux pas marcher ?
Sans ton sac ?
- Non, caporal.
- Tu peux pas respirer ?
Calme-toi. Le nez est bouché ou quoi ?
- Le nez, ça marche un peu, caporal.
Mais le poids...
- Partagez son sac, là, il vient derrière moi.
Moi, je veux avancer comme tout le monde, t'as compris ?
- Oui, sergent.
- On avance, camarade.
- Allez, donnez-lui son arme, là.
Allez.
Donne-moi ton arme. - Y a personne qui va te porter ici, Vafaina, t'as compris ?
- Oui, sergent. - Il n'y a personne qui va te porter, camarade.
Hein ? Si t'es pas capable de porter ton sac, ton arme, camarade,
t'as rien à faire ici.
On va pas te porter.
Pense pas qu'on va te porter 60 km, camarade.
Si tu veux un képi, tu vas marcher 60 km.
- Oui, sergent.
- Y a personne qui va te porter.
Si t'es pas capable de porter ton sac ni ton arme, tu vas voir.
Allez !
C'est bon, camarade, arrête de psychoter, là.
Tu lèves ta tête, t'as des couilles, t'es un homme, tu
marches.
Allez, lève la tête, on y va.
Avancez. On avance. On va
avancer.
Stop. Cours pas, camarade !
Marche ! Sinon, dans quelques minutes, on va devoir porter ton sac
aussi.
Allez, changement de sacs, là, voilà.
Tu peux marcher comme ça 60 km.
Hein ? - Oui, sergent. - Tu peux ou tu peux pas marcher ?
- Je peux marcher comme ça. - Tu peux marcher comme ça 60 km.
- Je vais essayer, sergent.
- Allez, mettez-vous en colonne, là.
En avant, en avant. Allez, camarades, on y va, on y va, on
y va. Allez, on arrive.
Allez, à droite, droite.
Respire, respire.
Hein ? Respire, hein.
Ecoute, t'es arrivé jusqu'ici, c'est bien.
Respire. Respire.
C'est bien déjà, il est arrivé jusqu'ici.
C'est très bien. On va...
On va faire notre possible pour l'amener jusqu'au bout.
Donne-lui un coup de main pour mettre son FAMAS.
Vafaina, devant.
- Vafaina, mets ton béret sur la tête.
Avancez.
- OK, stop.
Allez, laissez... Allez, donne un coup de main.
Changez les sacs. C'est bon ?
- Non, sergent.
- Regarde-moi.
Hein ? Qu'est-ce que tu sens ?
Il est où, le problème ?
- Je vois tout comme ça.
- Allez, on l'embarque.
Allez, on l'embarque.
- Viens avec les sacs.
- Récupère les sacs, on va l'embarquer.
- Fini pour lui, là ?
- Il va embarquer, il va nous rejoindre au point de ravitaillement là-bas,
on va voir comment ça se passe.
Il est pas en état de marcher.
Allez, monte. - Attention au FAMAS.
Mets le FAMAS devant. - Allez, monte.
- Symbole du soldat d'élite,
le képi blanc vous lie à la famille de la Grande Légion étrangère,
qui a perdu 36 000 de ses hommes depuis sa création en 1831.
Le képi blanc représente votre serment de servir avec honneur et fidélité
et de toujours respecter le Code du légionnaire.
Engagés de la 2ème section du lieutenant Lescop, coiffez vos képis blancs.
- Legio, patria nostra.
- Légionnaire !
- Tu es un volontaire
servant la France avec honneur et fidélité.
- Chaque légionnaire.
- Est ton frère d'arme, quelle que soit sa nationalité,
sa race, sa religion.
Tu lui manifestes toujours la solidarité étroite
qui doit unir les membres d'une même famille.
- Respectueux des traditions...
- Attaché à tes chefs, la discipline et la camaraderie sont ta force,
le courage et la loyauté tes vertus.
- Fier de ton état de légionnaire...
- Tu le montres dans ta tenue toujours élégante,
ton comportement toujours digne mais modeste,
ton casernement toujours net.
- Soldat d'élite...
- Tu t'entraînes avec rigueur,
tu entretiens ton arme comme ton bien le plus précieux,
tu as le souci constant de ta forme physique.
- La mission est sacrée...
- Tu l'exécutes jusqu'au bout
et, s'il le faut, en opération, au péril de ta vie.
- Au combat...
- Tu agis sans passion et sans haine.
Tu respectes tes ennemis vaincus,
tu n'abandonnes jamais ni tes morts, ni tes blessés, ni tes armes.
- Tu restes à la Légion étrangère, tu restes dans ta famille, dans ta compagnie.
Qu'est-ce que je t'ai dit à Noël ?
- On est tous de la même famille.
D'accord ? Donc tu restes dans ta famille.
Le képi blanc, c'est un passage, tu l'auras dans 10 jours,
quand tu auras réussi tout ce qu'on t'a demandé de faire.
Tu as bien compris ?
- Oui, mon lieutenant.
- Est-ce que tu as des questions à me poser ?
- Oui. Dans 10 jours, je refais la marche et j'aurai mon képi blanc ?
- Dans 10 jours, tu vas faire la marche et tu auras ton képi blanc.
D'accord ?
- Oui, mon capitaine.
- Voilà, c'est bien.
Daniel, lève la tête, aligne-toi !
Boualam, t'es pas aligné !
Kostrov, lève la tête !